[Applause]
[Music]
in a world that is facing unprecedented
increases in population ends with larger
and larger cities you could wonder two
cities have limits well the truth is
well yes that's why in some countries
they're opting for a much more drastic
solution than normal
I'm referring to the so called cities
from scratch but what exactly are cities
from scratch well with cities from
scratch we're talking about cities that
are created constructed and populated
where there used to be absolutely
nothing more than a vast expanse of land
or sea take for example Songdo in south
korea
Songdo which was also turned into a
special economic zone is one of the
world's greatest examples of what a city
built from scratch should be it's a true
example of success and while some of the
others they didn't go so well and some
they were a complete failure but let's
pause for a second some of you might be
thinking that this is a bit crazy I mean
isn't it too expensive to just build a
city from absolutely nothing well yeah
you're kinda lutely right
[Music]
China for example has used more concrete
in the last three years than the United
States did throughout the entire 20th
century but why are so many new cities
being built right now is it just about
offering more housing to the people
coming from the countryside or are there
more reasons behind it well let's take a
closer look
[Music]
the power of cities
it is a fact that power is concentrated
in cities and I'm not only talking about
political power here I'm also talking
about economic power industrial power
artistic power cultural power cities are
something of a cocktail of elements that
leads to a prosperity explosion
[Music]
and it's precisely beneath all that
prosperity that we find the reasons to
create new cities cities from scratch
but you may be wondering where the hell
are all of these new cities being built
well let's see in Europe I can think of
very few examples that fits but in
America there are some but they're on a
much smaller scale so where can they be
any ideas
well yes you've probably got it Asia is
the greatest proponents of new cities in
the world and within Asia there's one
country that has taken us to the extreme
China has built more than 600 cities
from scratch since the Chinese Communist
Party came to power in 1949 and not all
of these cities were built with the same
function in mind for example some are
centers of state or regional political
power others are oriented towards
logistics others are technological many
others seek to be trade and Finance
centers and of course some artists
chiefly residential however the bottom
line is that the purpose of the city
doesn't really matter they're all built
with a common ambition to be engines of
long-term economic growth china plans to
build new city nearly three times the
size of New York
[Music]
yes we're talking about an extreme case
of urban planning but market targeted
planning which doesn't necessarily mean
that it'll go well but you know we're
gonna see more about that in a bit the
point here is that the relationship
between cities and economic development
isn't only being pursued by China but
also by other developing countries that
are experiencing a fast transfer of
people from the countryside to cities
and I can tell you that this is
something we're gonna be talking about
in the future on visual politic so you
know be sure to subscribe if you're into
that you see this isn't only happening
in Asia in Africa there are projects
such as the UK Atlantic in Nigeria hope
City in Ghana Konza in Kenya or the new
administrative capital yeah that's the
name in Egypt of course in order for
this to be a success we need to know how
to build a city from scratch and for
that we must take many important things
into account such as location or to
supply capital investment public
transport and waste management's among
many other things and let's not forget
to create a city identity within which
people feel comfortable and integrated
as you can imagine all this is very
expensive that's why not all the cities
have worked as planned even considering
all the risk new city fever is very
common in several developing countries
so before we go on we need to consider
something do all cities follow the same
model are they all driven in the same
way listen closely to the answer because
it might just surprise you
[Music]
the paradigm of public and private
cities
yes folks you heard that right private
cities as with everything there isn't
just one way of doing things and
therefore there isn't a single city
management model now is true most cities
are driven and managed by the public
sector that is by the state by
governments but folks a small number of
them have been created and managed by
the private sector and some are more
successful than others but let me ask
you a question now what do you think of
the main differences between these two
models when we talk about private cities
you may imagine a huge wall with
security guards at the doors controlling
who can or cannot pass thought perhaps
charging a fee for entry well nothing
could be further from the truth
private cities are ordinary cities whose
only peculiarity is that they have been
designed built and later managed by one
or more private companies that is
instead of receiving services from the
public administration through the
municipality and taxes these services
are provided by private companies
through a kind of general service
contract that the residents sign when
they move in that is paid annually
perhaps one of the best examples of this
is arrest on
the rest on is a private city in
Virginia in the United States it belongs
to Fairfax County founders in the early
1960s it was conceived as a set of
company created owner communities and is
more or less continued this way to this
day these communities have their own
private security surface garbage
collection and public transport and it
looks like things have gone quite well
the city saw huge population growth
between 1970 and 1980 alone the
population skyrocketed from less than
6,000 to more than 36,000 which is a 536
percent increase in just 10 years
today more than 60,000 people live in
Reston and it makes sense Reston for
example there has been catalogued by a
CNN study as one of the best small
cities in the United States to live in
[Music]
and that isn't the only example
Lavar sir in India is a private city in
development that will have an area or a
hundred square kilometers and three
hundred thousand inhabitants when
completed today it's one of the best
places to live in India thanks to its
services in any event we'll need to see
if this way of making cities takes off
in the upcoming years because the truth
is most cities don't follow this private
model and folks let's not kid ourselves
a new city being public or private
doesn't define its success or failure
several factors come into play to make
cities as we want them to be troop hubs
of growth and prosperity and among them
the most important one is urban planning
with a vision of the future but also
remaining realistic and thinking about
the people well there is a country where
these basic concepts have gotten quite
out of hand so listen up becoming an
addict cities cities and more cities we
told you at the beginning China has a
clear idea in mind the future is in the
cities
[Music]
but to what extent when should a country
say stop we don't need any more cities
well folks the Chinese government
doesn't seem to want to see what the
rest of the world sees that they have a
bit of a problem they're going to need a
lot of people to and have it to their
mammoth cities that have been built from
scratch China's shrinking cities are
still addicted to building
despite population slump and of course
building a city with everyone else's
money leads to a huge illusion of
economic prosperity a lot of players
become involved in whole economic
sectors continue to work thanks to the
new cities construction for example
Chinese local governments have covered a
lot of their budget for years thanks to
real estate developments in these new
cities you see in the year 2000 land
sales accounted for 9.3 percent of
municipal revenues in China well
consider this in 2011 after more than 10
years of new city booms this amount
reached a whopping seventy four point
one percent of total revenues basically
they thought that founds the goose that
laid the golden eggs according to a
joint study done by land si Renmin
University and Michigan State University
Chinese municipalities and 40 times more
money selling lands for urban
development than they had to pay to
expropriate them and in the case of
lands reclaimed from the sea this ratio
could increase up to a hundred times
more with these numbers it doesn't seem
like bad business right
however just told on for a second before
we start ringing the bells of
celebration on the one hand local
governments spent all that money and
much more building infrastructure and
projects of all kinds but after rule
that seems like the money was always
it's going to just fall from the sky and
when the apartments were full of people
they'd get more and more money
there was such euphoria that several
local governments even ended up becoming
developers which led them to accumulate
a huge amount of debt but of course this
model is enormous Lee short-sighted and
is quickly losing ground in China I mean
if you extend the process to Marshall
ends up with dozens of completely empty
cities full of abandons or half built
residential blocks because nobody is
living in them and forget about new
taxes and all that of course the debt it
won't disappear well that's exactly
what's happening
[Music]
as you can see in the graph at the
national level a square kilometers bills
have already surpassed the units of
10,000 people living in urban areas and
10,000 inhabitants per square kilometer
is considered a good measure of
population density for the new Chinese
cities basically this means that the
rhythm of construction is already much
quicker than the urban population growth
required to occupy those new cities
that is the perfect recipe for building
empty cities or as they're known in
China ghost cities China local
governments hidden debt could total five
point eight trillion dollars so we could
say that the local Chinese governments
have been affected by something like the
Dutch disease the curse of natural
resources although in this case instead
of natural resources we have real estate
promotions that are financed and
promoted by China's own public banks
even so Chinese President Xi Jinping has
a very different opinion the President
himself has promoted the construction of
another new city from scratch as
personal project or the new area of
Shogun is an area or 120 kilometers from
Beijing that is connected by a 20-minute
trip from the Chinese capital by
high-speed train she wants it to become
a hub for the technology industry we're
talking about a completely ecological
city for which so many trees are going
to be planted that the forest cover in
the area will expand from 11 to 40% with
all this we can assure you of something
china plans to continue building new
cities despite having many empty or
clearly under populated ones so we must
ask ourselves will the Chinese new city
bubble definitely explode and if so how
will this affect their economy
[Music]
we've already told you the one of
China's features is its enormous level
of savings which may indeed finance all
of these wasteful expenses but is it
really reasonable to waste so much money
on cities that are often just ending up
empty will real estate developers and
banks go bankrupt what could happen to
the global economy if this true
addiction to building new cities
expanded to other developing countries
is it bread today and perhaps hunger
tomorrow I'll leave your answer in the
comments below and I really hope you did
enjoy this video please do hit that like
button if you did and don't forget to
subscribe for brand new videos also
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider Media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine also this channel is
possible because of patreon and our
patrons on that platform please do
consider joining them and supporting our
mission of providing independent
political coverage and as always I'll
see you in the next video
[Music]